our number is six one seven eight three
zero 4750 our next caller is from the
2:08 area code caller from 208 tell us
who this is and what's on your mind mr.
David Patten yes your honor there yes
I'm on alright this is Adam Chapman and
let me preface by saying that I really
enjoy your show I love it I love what
you do thank you I'm a huge fan
thank you the reason I give you that
preface is because I I feel that I might
concern you here with a moral dilemma
okay I watch your show yeah I also watch
Ben Shapiro be on his show okay I have
noticed that you share similar responses
yes okay so you hearing that does that
give you like a moral dilemma because
you're supporting these sponsors who
also support financially Ben Geppetto
and some of his views yeah so here's
what's going on everybody's using the
same ad agency everybody's using an ad
agency called mid-roll and they are not
political they'll work with anybody who
has an audience and has sort of like FCC
safe generally like work safe content so
there's you know Sam cedar and the
majority report has a lot of the same
advertisers and it's just it's a big
it's kind of like the big podcast ad
agency right now so yeah I mean Ben and
I share some advertisers and then we
don't share others that come through
mid-roll but there's there's really no
dilemma that I can think of okay good
thank goodness I know that the struggle
is real on that end right okay well glad
I was able to clear that up for you I
appreciate the call thank you David
no problem at all